- And this is the oversight on our part,
is we have not gone back and made our terms clear
in the world of large language models.
Large language models are wildly different from classic AI.
What AI was when we wrote those terms was different.
- Best part of hacking, when you can just, you know,
critical think, right?
- So Packers, we've got an exciting announcement.
Threat Locker Zero Trust World Conference is back in 2026.
It's gonna be March 4th to March 6th in Orlando, Florida.
It's freaking gorgeous down there too, during that time.
And yours truly is gonna be there.
I'm gonna be there on Wednesday, March 4th.
I'm gonna be leading a hands-on hacking workshop.
I'll be one of many.
So there's lots of fun hacking workshops
you can get involved in.
And it's gonna be a great time.
There's tons of sessions, workshops,
other people there to network with.
It's gonna be a great conference.
So if you're a local to Orlando,
or if you're up for the travel,
this is a great way for you to use
that employer training budget that you've got.
Also, for critical thinking listeners,
there's a discount of $200 off.
You can use the code ZTW, right?
For Zero Trust World.
ZTW, CTBB26, ZTW, CTBB26 when you register.
That'll be on the screen and in the description as well.
It's gonna be a great time.
I hope to see you guys there.
All right, let's go back to the show.
All righty, hackers, it's been a big week in Bug Bounty.
Lots of drama on Twitter about the whole hacker one thing.
And we've got a whole episode dedicated to that,
which I think should help address some of the issues.
But before we do that,
we're gonna jump into this week in Bug Bounty segment
to give you guys some quick news.
YesWeHack is continuing to crank out awesome guides
to bugs that go very in-depth.
And this week they put out an XML external entity,
XXE guide, and it has got a lot of data in here.
XXEs is one of those bugs where it comes out of nowhere
and it gets you like very impactful SRF, file read,
sometimes even RCE.
So if you're trying to land more criticals,
this is really one that you should look deeply into.
And I read through the guide here.
YesWeHack does a really excellent job
of providing a comprehensive summary
of how to find these
and different techniques for exploiting them.
So check it out.
Really good stuff in here.
They even cover like, you know,
language-specific stuff like PHP expect
and I believe some Java stuff as well.
So really good stuff here.
Next is something that is actually going to be launched
a couple of days before this episode releases,
but this is the bug bounty maturity framework.
And I know a lot of AppSec people
and actually program managers listen to this podcast as well.
So this is primarily for you all,
but also has impact on the researchers.
So let me explain what this is.
A guy that was on the team for critical thinking a while back,
Steve Hernandez,
he also worked for HackerOne for a while,
realized that there's no way for programs currently
to get an idea of where they are
as compared to other programs
and understand their maturity as a program.
So he took all of his knowledge of the industry
from his time working at HackerOne
and with critical thinking
and built this website, bugbountymaturity.com.
This is where you can take a quick survey to understand
where your bug bounty program lands
on a scale of emerging to leading
and how to level up to different tiers
and provide the best service to the hackers
and get the largest ROI out of your program.
So this is like a 15 question assessment,
but then it gives you very, very clear, you know,
stairs up to the next level, like do this, do this, do this,
and then you'll, you know, really be providing
and the best ROI, right?
That's the thing that's gonna move you to the next level
that the researchers are gonna feel the most
or that your organization is gonna feel the most.
I worked with Steve to build this out
and design the questions.
And I think that if more programs took this
and followed the steps inside of it,
the quality would really go up.
And we're actually even tossing around the idea
of doing some certification that goes along with this, right?
So when you see the bug bounty maturity framework,
you know, certification or whatever,
say, hey, we're at established or advanced or leading,
then you know what that means
and you know that you can trust that program.
So for any of you hackers that are interested,
so definitely feel free to take a peek,
but you program managers, AppSec teams,
I'd love for you guys to head over
to bugbountymaturity.com and take the assessment,
see where your organization is at
and see how you can improve your experience
for the hackers and for your org.
All right. I think that's it.
Let's cut to the episode.
We've got some really good stuff with Alex Rice,
CTO of HackerOne, where we address some of these issues
that have been put before the community
and put before HackerOne.
All right, man.
So we just got off that interview with Alex.
We're about to play that clip for you guys in just a sec.
Overall, I feel like that was pretty solid,
and I feel a lot better about how HackerOne
is using our report data.
- Yeah, he was super straightforward,
super willing to answer any question.
You went a little harder than I expected,
especially in the second half.
So people tune in for Justin kind of playing hardball there.
But no, I think that I was happy with all the answers.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, when I was roasting him about the bounties, right?
About reducing the bounties.
Yeah, I think he needed a roast for that.
I think he deserved a roast for that.
- And on the other part,
I just think that whenever you pressed
into some of those questions, right?
Like anytime his language was even a little bit vague,
you pressed into make sure it was clear.
I thought that was really good.
- Thanks, man.
All right, well, we're gonna jump into that clip.
I just wanna say before we do that,
and I add this comment as well in the actual recording,
but this was a interview
that we reached out to HackerOne for,
and we did not provide them with any questions in advance
or any ability to edit the content.
Everything said was on the record.
And I tried my best to represent you guys as the hunter
and how I felt as a hunter myself, obviously.
So definitely welcome any feedback you guys want in the Discord.
But I just wanted to disclaim that because HackerOne
is a sponsor, as is BugCrowd, as is YesWeHack,
as is Integrity.
But we made very clear to them in the beginning
that their sponsorship would have no effect on the content.
And I think we've held to that very well here.
- Yeah, and in general, Justin isn't big to toot his own horn,
but when Justin started critical thinking, that's the mission.
Like if Justin wanted to make more money,
he would just go do more bucket bounty hunting.
Like he does the podcast for you guys and for his friends.
And the whole point is the journalistic integrity
and the building of the community not to make more money.
So they're just sponsors because it makes sense.
And it kind of pays the bills.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Leaves me more time to hack, really, is why.
Because like my goal with this podcast was like,
let's get the team in place.
Let's get people like Richard, you know, doing awesome things,
taking care of it so that I can spend more time hacking
and then telling people about, you know, how amazing Bug Bounty is.
So, all right.
We've said our piece.
Let's cut to the clip.
All right, guys.
Well, here we are.
We are going to be covering some, some drama
that has been going down on Infosec Twitter as always.
And we are welcomed today by Alex Rice.
Thank you for joining us, HackerOneCTO.
And hopefully we can, I don't know, man.
Are you ready?
Ready for some, some, some grilling?
I love a good roast.
Thanks for having me on here, guys.
This is going to be fun.
All right, man.
Great, great.
He voluntarily did this.
We didn't like kidnap him and bring him on.
No, no, that was great.
And yeah, actually.
That's a good point.
I will, I will mention, you know,
because I said on the episode last week
that we were going to reach out for HackerOne for a comment.
And, you know, before, before everybody jumps on the like,
you know, train, because there are a lot of, you know, high,
high energy, high, you know,
tensions are high in the Bug Bounty community right now.
I want to disclose that HackerOne,
you know, is a sponsor of this podcast,
as is Bug Crowd and Integrity and Yes We Hack.
And, you know, we made it very clear from the very beginning that,
the content of critical thinking is sacred.
So when we reached out to HackerOne,
you know, to get a comment on this,
we invited them on the podcast to discuss this.
But, you know, we are not providing editorial,
you know, access to this.
And we're also not pre-prepping or anything like that.
So this is off the cuff on the record as much as we can.
And Alex, I appreciate you signing up for that.
Yeah, I appreciate the integrity here.
You got to keep it off, I think.
Yeah, yeah, we do.
So with that, man, all right, now we got to,
now we got to, you know, really represent the hackers here.
We're a little scared, man.
We're a little scared because, you know,
we're reading these terms of services.
We're looking at this marketing material that you guys are putting out.
And I think just speaking for the community in general right now,
you know, with so many things happening with AI,
it's and nobody knows which direction it's fully going to go.
And we have years and years and years of report data of our hard-won techniques,
you know, in the code, you know, in the HTTP requests, in the platform.
And to see something like those terms of service lines, you know,
implying that HackerOne may have the right to train AI models off of that data
is really scary for us.
So can you provide some clarification about why that is in your terms of service
and how you guys are using report data right now?
Yeah, well, let's start with that piece.
And then we should come back to the overall,
what is everyone just feeling right now?
What's going on with AI?
But our approach here, we are definitively not training Gen.AI,
fine-tuning, anything of that nature on researcher submissions,
which are also customer submissions at the same time.
We talked about a bunch of the reasons why that is.
Let's get into the detail of that.
What really kicked all this off was raising really good questions on our terms of service.
It does say we have the ability to, first of all,
our terms of service have been pretty restrictive from the beginning.
Hackers retain all of the IP to their services.
We have a license to utilize it to improve our,
provide and improve our services.
And then customers get a license to it.
So there's no ownership transmission here,
but there are some licenses that need to exist to operate the service.
And part of that, which we should get into why that exists there,
is the right to train models.
And why is that there?
One is because there's a number of things that happened here,
but it has been in place from the beginning.
And this is the oversight on our part is we have not gone back and made our terms clear
in the world of large language models.
Large language models are wildly different from classic AI.
What AI was when we wrote those terms was different.
I'll give you a real, real example here.
The very first ML model we put into place was over a decade ago.
It powered our spam prediction engine.
Every time a customer is clicking report spam on a report,
that goes into a rationality.
And every new report coming forward
has an updated spam classifier score on it, right?
Like that's training AI.
We call it machine learning.
Legal marketing teams call it AI.
That needs to get disambiguity now.
So it's really on us that we didn't catch that earlier
and we didn't fix that sooner.
We've tried to be really transparent with our technical documentation,
but not the terms.
And we got to get those two in line.
Hmm.
Okay.
Yeah, that makes sense.
And I understand that certainly spam classification is one of the big issues
that you guys have dealt with from the beginning.
And also that has been amplified since the AI onset here.
The one piece I'm going to read the most concerning line
from the Terms of Service right here.
It says, "HackerOne may use confidential information
to develop or improve its services.
For example, to identify trends and to train AI models,
provided such use does not result in disclosure of confidential information
to unauthorized third parties."
So as I understand it, that confidential information
is the user's full unredacted report.
And what I'm also wondering is whether HackerOne is using any of that report data
and making it anonymized, whether you're anonymizing the target,
anonymizing the researcher, but keeping the meat of those techniques in any way
and utilizing those in training, even your own internal products,
like the Pentest as a Service platform or anything beyond just the spam filter.
Yeah, it's a good question to get into what the broader piece of it is.
There is an anonymization process and an aggregate trend analysis that goes on.
I'm not using that today to train AI models.
And I think it's helpful to talk about why, why not?
Like, what are we doing?
What are we training models on?
Which is a bulk of what our material focuses on.
And I think we might, I'd love to get into this a little more later,
but I think what we're all seeing right now is the baseline foundation of models
are getting really good at finding vulnerabilities.
We don't view it as our place for that to be the thing that we differentiate at or really excel on.
I think the AI scaling laws are holding.
The models are getting better and better at this every single time one comes out.
It's just not central to our product strategy
or what's needed to even deliver these capabilities to really innovate and push there.
There's a ton of areas before and after the discovery of a bug
where AI is providing a ton of leverage to teams and hunters on both sides,
which is where we're applying quite a bit more of that analysis for things like,
what's the right triage decision?
What's the right prioritization decision?
As we were doing this pen test, how much of the scope wasn't covered?
What areas weren't there?
And so there's a lot more that goes into this than just discovery.
And I want to talk about them in pretty specific ways as we can get into them.
Yeah. Yeah.
So as you respond to that, a couple of things pop into my head.
You said that there is an anonymization component.
So I'm wondering what post-anonymization, what that data is being used for.
And two, you said that AI is being utilized to help determine
what piece of scope and stuff like that is being covered.
And so how is it doing that without access to the researchers' reports?
You can view it in the hacker-powered security report.
That's the primary output of the anonymized data set.
Okay.
And the second part of your question is, how is it doing that without access to the researchers' report?
So I guess the first part, I'm sorry, I got a lot of things I want to ask about here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'll take it one at a time.
So first, you said there is an anonymization component.
Where is that anonymized data going?
You said mostly the hacker-powered security report.
Is it completely the hacker-powered security report or is there some other...
It's the hacker-powered security report.
It gives you an example of what that data looks like.
So it's all anonymized and aggregated.
So it's things like powering the benchmark suite, the trend analysis, like what CVs are being
discovered most frequently.
And these are all pre-AI features.
So I wanted to give some examples of those of what that looks like.
It's not going into an LLM to determine the, you know, what's it called?
Like to determine like the types of bugs that are being submitted or anything like that.
It's all basically ML models or like tagging pre-LLMs that already were being used to generate
the security report for the year.
Yeah, but sorry, I want to be precise here as we talk about this.
There's not LLMs involved in any of that piece of data today.
Okay.
Yeah.
So that data isn't being ingested by LLMs or being utilized to enhance LLMs or fine-tune LLMs,
even in its anonymized state.
Yeah, that's right.
Okay.
Excellent.
Well, that makes you feel a little better.
That is good.
And I will say just as a hacker, I appreciate the hacker-powered security report.
Like I appreciate insight into what is happening in, uh, from the bug bounty.
You know, industry in general, it's being able to see those trends, being able to utilize
that to enhance my own methodology, you know, by looking at that material.
So I don't know, I don't want to speak for the whole community here.
And I know that I am a little bit less privacy conscious conscious than most, um, you know,
people are in our industry.
But I think that that is not only helpful for the bug bounty community and helpful for you guys
as a platform, but, um, in, you know, specifically helpful to the hacker to be able to enhance their
own methodology.
Yeah.
So I think if we like, we want to talk about a principle here for a second, the principle we're
trying to not violate is the research submission is the researcher's data.
It is their property.
Um, it's in a strange way to share with both a customer and with us.
And so there's two points where, um, there's potential for other people to see your property
and, and, and learn techniques and things, and things around it.
So I can provide really definitive statements on, um, what we're doing with RAA that doesn't violate
that principle and that, and that, and that practice.
And I also want to say why we try to be so transparent about this is we haven't made a
major mistake there yet.
There's a chance that we do, and we want to find out about it as soon as we do.
So we want to know specific examples.
Anytime somebody has seen a, um, well, I think I was using this technique and now
someone has found out about it over here.
How, how, how did that happen?
We investigate those pretty regularly.
We've had some insider incidents in the past that point to that, um, whether it's an insider
or an AI model or a customer or any other way that it happens.
Um, we, we take those really seriously.
We want to know about those.
We want to investigate those.
And we're, we're, we've taken a lot of safeguards to not do that with AI.
And if we are doing that, like, if you find areas where you think that might have happened,
let us know about it.
We want to go investigate.
We want to go figure out how that happened.
We want to get to source the truth on it.
Um, I, I don't see how it'd be our AI models today, but it's like that accountability loop driven
by transparency is a key part of making this thing.
Yeah, or go ahead.
I was just going to say, I think that like, um, the way you keep saying it's our property,
like for some reason, like it doesn't ring true for me because I've always understood bug bounty
as like, I'm giving up my IP in order for it to be paid.
Like basically I, I like, I basically, when I submit it, I'm kind of like agreeing to the company's
terms to like not disclose this without their permission.
And, um, so I don't know, I would just love a little more clarity around that.
Cause if like, if that's not the case, that actually makes me feel like awesome.
You know, like I feel like whenever, whenever I like, I've always assumed to end bug bounty,
it's actually not my intellectual property anymore.
That's actually the company's and maybe hacker ones.
And so like, if I want to keep, if I want to keep the rights to myself,
I need to email it into security at instead.
Yeah, not, not, not, not the case, but let's get, let's, let's dive into this for a second.
I'd encourage you to go back and refresh with, I'm going to quote the actual terms here.
Cause I, we put a lot of time and energy, you know, I think they actually work, but the section
eight of the community terms, uh, you retain all intellectual property rights.
You give hacker one a pretty limited license solely for purposes of improving and providing
our, our services so that it prohibits a ton of stuff like us reselling it or, um,
you can go through the, the, the restrictions on it.
The customer has a slightly more permissive license for it.
They're allowed to, um, do whatever is necessary to improve and secure their own attacks, their own
attack service.
So that you're right.
Like it is your IP, but you are giving up a pretty unrestricted license to it, to the customer.
Less so to hacker one, RSS web more restrictions on it.
Um, but when it goes to the customer, that is where you're losing.
And that's where like when we have really strong assurances about making sure none of this ever
makes it out anywhere else.
That is where these things do intentionally, uh, eventually tend to come out is a customer's
threat Intel sharing feeds or, uh, their own remediation teams or their CBE advisories.
Like eventually this makes it into the common pool of knowledge, which other hackers start picking up
on and hundreds are incentivized to try to delay that as long as we can.
But it inevitably happens if purely through active remediation efforts.
And that's where most of this is making it into the models we, we, we, we, we suspect.
And so there's a little bit of a time delay in a half-life on these where we view it as our
responsibility not to violate that trust, not to accelerate it unnecessarily.
But I think some of the anxiety that we're feeling is that that is accelerating.
Like that loop between new type of, of exploit has been identified and scanners,
AI scanners are now finding it effectively is, is a lot shorter than it was in the days of rapid seven.
Yeah.
And I, I think that is definitely a component of it.
And I will say as somebody who I, you know, I had one of my zero days that I reported get yoinked
and, uh, you know, used, and I went through hacker ones, you know, process to address that.
And we, we got to the root of it very quickly.
And, uh, you know, that person was, uh, not a hacker one employee, but they, they were reprimanded
by their employer that was a hacker one customer.
Um, I was satisfied with that, with that process.
And that is a risk, you know, that, that we have when we, when we submit.
And I've, I've seen you guys personally, you know, take serious, you know, precautions
to try to, to try to, um, address that.
So that, that, that is certainly reassuring.
I'm wondering if there's any way, like, what way should we report these things to you
that you say you would like to know about?
Like if there's some way that our techniques have been leaked out, or we feel like our techniques
are being utilized by AI or something like that, what, what is the best way that we can get that
back to you for investigation purposes?
Yeah, great, great question.
The easiest way, if there's a specific report you suspect is, is involved there, the, the mediation
button is the, the cleanest way to track it.
For some reason you don't trust that, grab, grab your H, HSP, submit it into our bounty program,
or, or, or reach out to one of us directly.
If you think there's something really sus going on, hit our, our legal team directly at, at legal
at or privacy at.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
I think it could be a valuable thing for you guys to set up some sort of, um, you know,
specific email or something like that, that we could, that we could email directly to, to sort
of address these issues that, that could be something that would increase hacker trust moving forward,
just to have a way that we can express these concerns and get sort of one-on-one, uh, you know,
answers to some of these more sensitive questions.
Yeah.
I, I, I'm, as you talk about it, I, I don't even know what to point you to other than report it.
So that's a brilliant call out.
We'll, we'll, we'll action that right away.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think that'd be great.
And hackers don't use that as like a second mediation path.
You use it for legitimate leaks.
This is why we can't have nice things.
Yeah.
Like, yeah, that's kind of our, our responsibility is like, whether it's a whistleblower
complaint or, or, or something else, it's, it's on us to investigate all, all of us.
Yeah.
We'll use the ML models to, to spam, figure out whether the report is spam.
No, um, that's great.
Um, well thank you for, for that.
And, and I guess I'm going to press a little further here into this because there's not
just the piece of like, you know, are you fine tuning AI models here, but there's also the pen
testing as a, as service platform that you guys have just released.
So, um, some of the concerning quotes from the, um, marketing material for that are as follows.
Um, agents are trained and refined using proprietary exploit intelligence informed by years of testing
real enterprise systems paired with robust verified, uh, community of elite pen testers.
So when we read this, it kind of sounds like, oh, our proprietary exploit intelligence
that we've been giving you all, you know, all these years is going into the training of these pen
test, uh, as a service, um, platforms.
Uh, so I guess the data for that, the data that has informed the prompt or the rag or,
you know, whatever you're using to, to make this, um, you know, agentic, uh, pen test as a service
platform, um, where is that coming from?
Yeah, um, this, this, this, let's, let's pick this, pick this part into a few different topics
here.
So one, the marketing material that you just quoted out to your, um, uh, Patrick, uh, called
this out also.
We, we went back and corrected that right away.
So there's some new texts on there that reflects a little bit more better, but separately from that,
uh, about two weeks before we published the marketing launch, we published a security
architecture of the P test system that goes into really specific detail.
And you'll notice we don't have the confusing training language in, in there.
So let me jump to that question.
Okay.
Actually, before we do this, let me like just how it's all context switch for a second
on what is hacker one's P test?
Cause we're not really known for it.
It's a meaningful portion of the business.
They launched it back in 2018.
We got into the pen testing business and the, the reason we did it was one of the biggest
things holding back more companies adopting bug bounty is assessing if they're ready for it or not.
And we were running into this problem.
We regularly would have companies coming and be like, we want a bounty program.
We love it.
We're so secure.
And we have all these things where like, well, let's assess your maturity and make sure you're
ready for that.
And one of the most common things we'd run into is we have a pen test.
We've been doing this pen test for five years and we've never had a finding.
Like we are good to go.
Like let's go launch a bounty program and we're like, see that?
Can we see that?
And so we really started doing pen tests through a defense in depth mindset of you've,
you've really got to approach these things.
You can't just decide bug bounty is going to be the first thing that I do to secure myself.
If you've been doing a check the box, $2,000 compliance pen test for the last five years,
you're not going to be ready for this.
And we viewed it as a comprehensive customer offering as part of it.
And our flavor of pen testing, very high end.
They're not cheap.
It's not meant to be a compliance.
We tell people out the gate, like, look, if you're just trying to get compliance,
there are many pen test vendors that will do that.
It's all community powered.
Sometimes they overlap with hunters.
Not always.
Not every hunter is a pen tester.
But it's about 200 pen testers from the community that do these pen tests today.
So that's the background.
2018 going into now.
I have heard of this.
So this is where you guys are giving pen tests out to, you know, the bug bounty community.
And there's like a lead pen tester and stuff like that.
And they're performing the pen test.
The lead pen tester like puts it all into the report and works with the client and that sort of thing.
That's exactly right.
Okay.
So that's that component.
This is really interesting because I'll let both of you talk in a second.
But when I've heard Ptas mentioned in the last week, I think it's been in like the same vein as all this stuff.
And it because it ends in AAS, I think it was all.
Yeah, I thought it was some new offering that was all automated.
I like I've done a few pen tests through hacker one.
So does that does that mean that like am I just like actually confused?
And when you all say Ptas, you actually just being manual hackers from the crowd.
I wouldn't use the term manual there.
But yes, our Ptas offering always has a human event.
Even our agentic Ptas offering.
So maybe we're just differentiating between the agentic Ptas and the other one.
But I think Justin and I are mostly asking about the agentic Ptas and not just like your genus.
Yeah.
So let's go there now.
Let's talk about pen testing in 2026.
None of our pen testers are not using AI agents today.
Right.
Like it's just we should talk more broadly.
Anyone trying to do bug activation day.
If you're not already ramping up on that, you kind of need to be.
And our pen test community has been leaning in on this pretty early on.
And there's components of it that should stay with the individual pen tester.
They're really tailored to their toolkit in there.
And there's components of a pen test that really need to happen at scale ahead of the pen test even
starting for everybody engaged in the pen test and need to be interactive with the lead pen tester.
So that's what our agentic Ptas looks like.
It's meant to be operated by humans.
We get into this like, is an agent fully autonomous?
Is any human?
I'm not that far on the AI hype scale.
All the AI we're deploying has a heavy human loop component and they're agents meant to be orchestrated by human experts.
In this case, the lead pen tester or actually all the pen testers, but predominantly the lead pen tester in the pen test.
So that, yeah, if I, if I could ask about that, then like, that makes sense.
I think everybody should be doing it.
Just like we said, we've said that on the pod a ton, um, that can, that, you know, lead pen tester that is utilizing this agent that you guys have built.
You know, obviously they're, they're working hand in hand with the agent, right?
The, this agent has it, has it seen, has it seen techniques from reports?
Has it, w where is it getting all this data this years?
I mean, what did it say?
Like, um, years of testing, real enterprise systems intelligence formed by years of testing,
uh, real enterprise systems.
Like where did that years of, of experience come from?
Is that that eight 2018 to, you know, 2026, uh, where you guys have been working with, you know,
in the pen test as a service environment?
Like, are those reports going to feed the AI or is it bug bounty reports or is it some separate dataset?
Yeah.
So none of the bug bounty reports, um, the datasets, and I, I should have sent you the speed architecture,
but the, the five areas where it gets that intelligent from.
The first one is public benchmarks.
We try to pull all of those in to make sure that pass those.
The second one is we invested in building a bunch of internal benchmarks.
A lot of the pen testers helped and contributed to building those.
Um, there are custom vulnerable apps that we,
that we've created for that try to replicate a pen test, pest testing environment.
There's public CVs and disclosures.
This is the only area where there's potentially overlap with the bug bounty commission because
a big percentage of CVs today originated as bug bounty submission.
So there is some contamination that, that occurs through that process.
And the fifth one, which is where most of the real power comes from is what we call sidecar runs.
And these are done where, um, both the, um, pen tester and the customer has opted in to run the two of them in, in parallel.
Um, so we've been doing those more recently and it really compares.
What, what does this look like in kind of an isolated environment?
And what does it look like in, in this, in, in this trained environment?
Okay.
So sidecar runs are, are, are, are what?
The, the AI is watching what's happening on both sides of the spectrum.
Is that like, like, like on the researcher side and on the customer side?
That's right.
And this is where I, it's, it's worth being precision because if we were doing this to
in the, in the, in the bug bounty space, it'd be really confusing.
Yeah.
Right.
But the, the pen testing is a different engagement model works differently.
There's pretty clear consent and, and opt in and the dynamic there is, is different, right?
Like pen testers are a bit more of a hourly grind for lack of a lack of a better term.
Sure.
And the efficiency you get from AI is, is huge there.
Yeah.
Like, and so there, there's a little bit less of this contention there.
So we, we operate with the same principles, but that's a, it's, it's a pretty different
world than, than bug bounty hunting and bug bounties.
I totally agree.
And I think that especially if both parties opt in, that's fine.
I, I am wondering what that looks like though, just out of curiosity, like, are, are you guys
processing you like, do you have the pen testers like turn in their Kaido project or their burp
project and like, you know, then you guys analyze off those HTTP requests or is it, you know,
the questions that the researcher is asking the AI, you know, like how are you utilizing the data
in these side cart runs?
It's, it's, it's all of the above for this.
And I don't want to get into this because the team's iterating where this is one of the,
And I know this is like being clear in AI is how fast it moves.
Right.
Um, but let me just say, um, one of the reasons why I say it's that is something we
think works really well in our pen test offering is that we try to bring as much diversity as we
can actually, this is what works well in the bug bounty offering.
So if we talk about like, is there going to be one AI agent that can do your pen test for you?
Put me on the far end of skeptic for that.
Like I don't think that's the world we're getting to in the near future.
It's, it's going, like it's getting better.
Um, but could you just like, but okay, I've picked, I've done my enterprise RFP.
I evaluated a bunch of AI pen testing stuff and I've picked the best AI pen tester.
Like, am I good to go?
Is that all I need?
I, I, I don't think so.
I think you're going to need a real diversity of agents running.
I think you're still going to need bug bounty and community submissions running after that.
And even if bugs are getting more scarce and good, like I would love to see pen testing level
up to the level where it actually, where it actually does that.
Um, so when we are doing these, our pen testers have a lot of individual by design freedom to
use different tools.
And so that's when it gets into the, what is it actually?
I, I forget the stats off the top of my head, but there is no single pen testing suite
that's used by a majority of the, the pen testing groups that we have by, by design.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, that, that makes sense.
And man, yeah, there's so many, there's so many pieces to this and components to this,
but it does, I mean, at the end of the day, excuse me, for me, it boils down to that, that
piece of like, okay, bug bounty reports are not being utilized.
Anonymized bug bounty reports are not being utilized.
What is being utilized is, you know, consenting pen testers and consenting clients for that
data to be processed and used to enhance the, the agentic component.
And the goal of that...
Also, just to make a pause for a second here, to interrupt your question.
Yeah, no, you're good.
Just to, I'll tell our marketing team to cover their ears for a second because they're, they're here.
Most of the capabilities here are coming from foundation models.
Yes.
Like, let's just all be, let's all be clear about this.
Yeah.
Well, a lot of the value providing is around this like last mile.
How do you make that really usable to enterprises?
Because I think that's where we're uniquely positioned to provide a lot of the value here.
But when we look at pen testing, the bar is so low.
Mm-hmm.
We don't need an AI like up to date, trained on the 10,000 best hackers in the world.
Like it's just not needed to have meaningful step change functions in the state of pen testing today.
Totally.
It's just not.
Yeah.
And I think that's, I mean, Joseph, that's kind of like what you and I have talked about
out of band as well, which is like, we've done a lot of experience experimenting with like fine-tuned
security oriented models.
And so far, you know, the, the frontier models, right.
Have, have taken the cake, uh, as far as performance by a large margin.
So, you know, even you, you know, and these are massive data sets they're training off of too,
you know, um, to make these security, uh, models.
So I think that general intelligence at this point is going to outweigh, uh, you know,
fine-tuned models on, even if it was fine-tuned on researcher reports, right.
Which it's not, I think it would still outperform, uh, you know, the, the frontier models
would outperform that, that fine-tuned model.
Yeah.
I, I want to mention that just to assuage the fears of bug hunters that are listening that do think like,
oh, now if, if some, you know, model providers snap, like were to acquire hacker one or bug crowd,
they'd be able to use that data to then make it like way better.
And I'm just not convinced that's the case.
Like I actually think that so much of these models, uh, improvements comes from having
just like large access to huge data sets.
And, and so much of the improvement that have been made to its ability to hack is actually
just in its ability to code, right.
Because coding and hacking do have like a lot of overlap.
And so its ability to write little one-off scripts to test things, I think has been,
what has been massively leveling up things like cloud code, for example.
And that, um, if, if they, if a company were to like, if hacker one were to fine tune, uh,
GPT four, um, on like all of the reports in hacker one, I actually don't think it would be
that, that, that, um, much of an improvement if, if any.
I agree.
So, yeah.
And so anyways, if, yeah, so you all probably aren't even going down that route or if you,
or if there are people internally at hacker one that are like trying to push you to do that,
Alex, this is like some good logic for like, should we really do that?
Um, and, and one of the big issues with that is that like, what percent of all your submissions
are high quality, you know, it's like a very low percentage.
Right.
And ever, everyone knows that who's managed a program.
And so if there was something down the road where you all did consider it, I think a much
better model would be like, you know, pay the best bug hunters a certain amount per high quality report.
Now you have a very refined, good data set that is actually, you know, worth training on or something
like that.
But yeah.
Yeah.
I agree.
I think, I think some researchers would definitely, the more green hat researchers would definitely,
you know, be cool with that.
I think.
So, um, yeah, it hasn't proven to be necessary yet.
And if, if it were, I don't know if it'd be our place to do it.
Yeah.
Cause at the end of the day, researcher trust is paramount really.
And, and that is an essential component of the model for hacker one.
Right.
It is, is this trusted middleman, you know, that's going to work with you and, and, and, and advocate
for you in scenarios where, you know, uh, you need that and, and vice versa for the, for the programs.
Right.
Um, so I think, uh, maintaining that, that trust is paramount.
I did want to, I did want to ask though, you know, we've, we've been around the block in the security
world a little bit and, you know, as AI is getting more and more and more traction, um, it seems to
be that private equity does want to come in and force the hands of some organizations to,
to utilize that data for other purposes.
And I'm wondering if you guys, as somebody who's on the C-suite of hacker one, I'm wondering if you
guys have had pressure on that front to address, you know, selling that data or using that data for AI purposes.
And I want to separate the two of those out because, well, we, we need to go clarify our term to draw a distinction
between the different types of AI that are out there.
The, uh, selling the data is something that it would, is, is more clearly defined in, in, in there.
Um, but also just from an overall company health perspective, we've been kind of fortunate.
We were a little bit paranoid founders.
We were pretty selective with our board early on.
We've got VCs that have a very long, uh, time horizon.
Um, and we've, we've tried to run the business really efficiently.
There were a number of years we ran it free cashflow positive and, and have tried to balance
as much of that with the researcher growth in the research community as possible.
So we're not in a position that I feel like that's kind of a state of right now.
It doesn't like, this is something that should be on, on everybody's mind.
It's like, uh, who can predict five years into the future on something, but I'll say really
definitively right now, there's been no pressure to sell to another firm or, or, or operated any
differently.
Okay.
All right.
Well, I'm glad to hear that.
I, I think that that is the, the right choice.
Um, so I hope, I hope that continues to be the case over the longterm.
Um, is this overall anxiety happening across everybody?
Like not, you're kind of reminded of it.
There's like a, a, a pretty, uh, viral blog post that went out.
We can have a go of like something big is happening.
And as I, as I've been sitting with that for the last week, something big is happening.
And it's, it's like everywhere, everything all at once.
And it's, it's, uh, it's, it's, it's kind of nuts, but kind of exciting at the same time.
And I, I do think we're in a period of pretty intense transformation.
Like the way this looked is, is changing pretty, pretty significantly.
And the one message I wanted to be here is like, if you're still in a position where
this is not meant to assuage transparency or help, force us to be transparent, force
accountability on us.
That is our responsibility.
We are very committed to that.
But at the same time, you cannot be afraid of AI right now.
If you are not using AI in your bug hunting, if you're not using it in your pen testing,
you've got to lean in, like go download vanilla cloud code or Shannon or Artemis or Strix.
Like these tools are really powerful in the hands of a professional.
Yeah.
I agree.
Thanks.
Thanks for that.
And, and I, I, you know, on the flip side of this, I'll, I'll commend you guys and say,
really like, please continue to value researcher trust and as paramount, because, you know,
if that degrades, it becomes really hard from, from our side to continue, you know, giving bugs.
And, and I appreciate you coming on here and protecting that, um, with us and answering the
hard questions and letting us badger you a little bit about it.
I know I asked you like three or four times, is there any component of the, you know,
uh, is the template of the report being fed to AI?
Um, you know, but, and I appreciate you, you know, taking the time to, to, um, address those,
those concerns.
And if you guys continue to do that, you will continue to have a researcher base that is
strong and producing good bones.
As excited as I am about AI agents, improving security.
We are a long way away from not meeting security researchers.
I think it's going to be now more than ever, at least for the, the, the immediate future.
Yeah.
Joseph, any closing thoughts?
I mean, I, I think that, um, in general, you know, it's like, like you said, the anxiety,
at least in my opinion, I think that I was like less worried about it until, like you said,
the last few weeks have definitely felt like something is happening.
And I think it's the fact that, you know, everyone I know is now using
you know, coding agents to basically level up their hacking in such a way where they're
finding more vulnerabilities.
And I think that's just like on net perfect.
Like, I think that's amazing for us societally.
I also think that it goes to show the ease with which companies will be able to implement this on
their side, which I do think will reduce the amount of exposed, um, insecure, you know, code that kind
of touches us, but also, you know, I think that, you know, vibe coatings and they continue to, to
crank out and, you know, it's not even really vibe coding anymore.
Cause I think like people are using it internally seriously.
Right.
So like saying vibe coding is almost the wrong word, but I think that people, you know, inside
enterprises are rolling out way more code than they were able to before.
And obviously that's going to have stuff that gets missed.
But my, my, um, my impression is that I think, you know, there is going to be kind of like a land
grab for those low, for the low hanging fruit, you know, the bottom 20, like where, whereas before
the low hanging fruit was like bugs that you found via full automation, which was maybe like,
let's say 1% or 2% of bugs, I think there's going to be a little bit of a land grab for the bottom 50%
now over the course of the next nine months.
Right.
Or the next six months.
I agree.
Yeah.
And so I do think that does worry me a little bit, because at the end of that, it's like,
things are really secure, which is amazing for, for like the security of the human race,
but also like, it also kind of makes it kind of tough.
Right.
It's things like, I do think they will kind of dry up and my hope and my, you know, recommendation
to programs would be like, at that point, if you do start to receive far less bugs,
offer more money for better bugs.
Right.
And then hopefully you keep us in the game a lot longer and then you keep fighting more.
Yeah, actually, now that we're, now that you mentioned that Joseph, I, well,
I've got, I've got you on here, Alex.
I did want to address one more thing.
Like w we also saw a decrease in bounties on hacker one's bug bounty platform.
You guys, uh, you know, decreased them pretty substantially.
And, um, I, you know, I, I'm not sure if I, if you're the right, I mean, obviously you're the
right rep in the organization to talk about what's happening with these products and where the data
is going and stuff like that.
I'm not sure how actively involved with you, you are with hacker one's own bug bounty program,
but do you have any insight into why that happens and why we're not, you know, keeping bounties at
the same level or increasing them to try to send positive signals to the other programs, um, in the ecosystem?
Yeah. So I, I, the security team rolls up into me.
And so, um, um, that I am a hundred percent the right person.
And ultimately it was the one who made the decision on that.
And we're like, we've got kind of a tale of two areas here.
Like you're, you're very, uh, the, the AI thing is a really fun conversation.
This is the one I probably deserve a little bit more of a roast on because we do need to be thoughtful.
We need to get a ton of feedback from the community on this, because this really is a feedback.
So we're, we're constantly adjusting our, our structure of our, of our bounty program.
And one of the things we adjusted, uh, this last quarter was we were previously targeting
the top 1% benchmark for our program, which much we were benchmarking ourselves against Google,
Amazon, Meta, similar security ambitions, but very different security budgets.
Right.
Um, and it broke a lot of stuff in how we were looking at our program.
Like we were an ex we're an extreme outlier on the platform and remain that.
And the team's really trying to be more data driven about why is that happening?
What are the different levers here?
And one of the levers they, they came to be wanting to pull was we'd like to follow the advice
we give our own customers and benchmark ourselves closer to our ambition.
So we've changed our benchmarking group from kind of the cloud hyperscalers to high growth tech company.
And that, that looks a little bit, a little bit different.
It means we're right now targeting about the 80th percentile in bounty.
So it's still pretty competitive bounties are still in the, in the top quartile,
but it wasn't a drop before most meaningful drop was in lows and mediums, which is something
that we have has a question that's been on the team's mind for a while is we have historically
really incentivize the discovery of lows.
And as we're in a period of pretty intense transformation, our own technology stack,
we've seen a bit more attention go there than we wanted to.
And so we, we moved to the 80th percentile that impacted the lower tier of it the most.
And then the other debate the team was having is, should we continue to have one critical definition
across the entire platform, or should we start splitting it up based on these things here?
And the team landed on one simple definition for critical, which meant there's instead of having,
and most programs, you'll see different definitions of critical across different assets.
We've maintained one definition of critical across everything that we build right now.
That's the one thing I'd like the most feedback on.
And we're gonna be paying the most attention to as we monitor this, but the team's looking at it
really closely. If engagement does change, or it looks like our overall spend is dropping,
we'll be adjusting it back up, but think of it a little bit as a data exercise. And it's, I really
regret that these things are happening at the same time. In hindsight, we should have pushed this out
a little bit, a little bit further, but they truly were disconnected from each other.
It's okay. And I think, I think, you know, hindsight is 20/20. And as we, I think as we navigate these
difficult business decisions, right, and they happen at the same time, you know, nobody's going to make the
perfect calls. Um, as I listened to you, you say that my response to that is that makes sense for
a company that is running a bug bounty program. I don't think it makes sense as much for a company
that is a bug bounty platform, you know, because not, not only are like, I, I like that you guys are
holding to, you know, I understand the idea to hold yourself to the top, you know, quartile rather than,
you know, the top 1% or whatever. And, but I also think you've got to understand that
what's happening here as far as the bounties, you know, sets trends for the rest of the organization
and for the rest of the industry in general. So, you know, when we see that as researchers, I'm not
super bummed out. I'm not like, you know, the, the hacker one is not one of my main programs. You guys
are, you guys are, are tight. Um, but you know, but when I look at that, I think, man, that's the signal
that's being sent to the rest of the bug bounty, bounty community, which is that bug bounty is in
such a state right, right now that the, you know, hopefully the most invested player is decreasing their
bounties. And that is, is scary.
Yeah. It's, it's really good feedback. I do think that the thing we had the most debate
on and that we're honestly still debating a bit is should we have two bug tiers? So critical for us
right now is any confidential information to get sysposed. And most of the criticals we paid out
were not access to bug reports. So we have been debating a, like, do we need a tier? We wanted to
keep the bar where critical was broader than just bug reports, but bug reports are in a next level of
impact for us. Like the reports that we get where, oh, I could get access to a vulnerability submission
that wasn't mine. Those are, those are really rare. We haven't had one in a while and they're, they're
much higher level. And so I do think the, the, both the incentive we want to drive in the program
and, uh, what we want to signal to the broader community, had we gone with that kind of bifurcated
critical definition might have helped it, but really good feedback. And then anyone else who has
thoughts on this, please, please send it in. Truly posted folks that are engaged in our
programs. Just give it examples. Like the team's really engaged, really responsive feedback. And I,
I want to make sure we got the mark right on this one. Okay. Yeah. I would, I would love to see a
readjustment here, um, as a hacker, like in, and either revert the changes or, um, add some additional
clarity to the policy page or your, your, or maybe even have like an exceptional tier, right? Like a,
like a, you know, uh, you know, an exceptional tier or a multiplier if you get access to a vulnerability
submission that's not yours yet. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think that would be, I think that would be great.
Yeah. I wonder if like the bulk of the funds that were leaking, that puts you all over budget on that
would, were all from the loads and mediums, you know, and downgrading that would have mostly, you
know, cleared up the, the, the, any budget issues or any alignment issues there. So it's more of a
capacity and bandwidth issue than a, than a budget issue. Um, we don't expect the budget to change
dramatically because we're spending quite a bit more in, in, in other areas and, and pre-production
testing. So it's, um, um, but yeah, really, really good, good point. I, I, and also I'm looking at this
and I, and I'm seeing, you know, lows going from a hundred, you know, to a thousand down to a hundred to
two hundred and mediums. That was the biggest change. Yeah. Well, I, I disagree. I think that the,
I think that seeing lows go from, you know, one hundred, one hundred to a thousand to 100 to 200.
Right. And then in mediums going from 2,500 to 1,500, I'm much less worried about, but seeing
highs go from 12, 12,500 to 7k and crits go from 25 K to 15 says, Hey, even our, our, you know, bigger
vulnerabilities, we're, we're paying less. Like everybody understands, Hey, you know, look, we've
got this HTML injection. We ought to clean it up. We got to give them a bounty. It's here's a couple
hundred bucks. No, no serious bug hunter is, is going to bitch about that. Right. But like, if, if we
give you a good report, that's a high, you know, and, and we just lost five grand off the top of that,
or 10 grand off the top, like that, that stings. Does that make sense?
Yeah. It does. It does. It does. And I think it, it, it adds more weight to the earlier suggestion
of we need multipliers for the, the categories of bugs that are impactful in submissions.
Right. Cause sometimes a CVSS high isn't the same as a CVSS high, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. All right. Well, thanks for listening to that, Alex. I appreciate that. And, and I would love to see
some, some changes on, on that table if possible. And, and if you do have the ability to put out that tip
line, you know, as we suggested for, um, abuse of hacker reports, either with the, they're getting
fed into AI or that they are, um, you know, being taken by triagers or, or members of the programs,
uh, or whatever, I think that would be a great thing for the community. Um, so thank you for
listening to our, our feedback on this. I'm going to get the, the instructions for the, the tip line out
there. Um, as a team consider an exceptional tier and please keep, keep holding us accountable in
this way. This is a, it's essential to have these types of conversations.
Of course, Alex. Thanks so much, man.
Cool. Take care guys.
All right. That's a wrap on the interview. I'm really glad Alex came on and discussed some
of that stuff with us. Um, if you guys are still a little worried about this, that makes sense,
drop any concerns you guys have in the discord and we'll kind of discuss further. And yeah,
if we need to get any more clarifying factors, uh, from hacker one, um, definitely sounds like they're
going to put together that tip line or whatever to get more questions and concerns from researchers
heard, uh, which I think is a step forward. And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for watching to the end y'all. If you want more critical thinking content, uh,
or if you want to support the show, head over to ctbb.show/discord. You can hop in the community.
There's lots of great high level hacking discussion happening there on top of the masterclasses,
hack alongs, exclusive content, and a full-time hunters guild. If you're a full-time hunter,
it's a great time. Trust me. I'll see you there.